Tamm Bridge house school in Horsham West
Sussex rated outstanding by Ofsted this
secondary like many others is struggling
financially with spending per pupil down
8 percent in real terms since 2010 and
council services being cut by half in
the same period budgets are under
pressure her teacher Jules white has
been working with other school leaders
to lobby for more funding through the
campaign Group worth less it's clear
he's frustrated with the political
response I'm in contact the thousands
have had teachers and they're talking to
me all the time about pressures they
come in all different shapes and sizes
sometimes it's the basic sometimes it's
equipment sometimes it's building often
though it's about staffing and capacity
levels all school budgets 90% are
wrapped up within staffing if you
haven't got the money then you don't
have the staffing levels class sizes go
up you can't provide the type of
one-to-one support particularly for
youngsters with special needs or those
from disadvantaged backgrounds
we're squeezed and as one head teacher
said to me I just don't sleep at night
it's a constant source of worry and what
kind of difficult decisions have you had
to make as well
the biggest concern I've had over the
last year is trying to provide the type
of support that young people with
special educational needs require I have
21 children who have a educational
health and care plans this statement is
providing them with additional support
but I actually only have 18 full-time
equivalent ta so I don't even give their
ta is their teacher teaching assistant
and I don't even have the one-to-one
support for those youngsters but I'm a
school of 1600 I've got one or two
hundred other children who have
particular learning needs what do I do
about them I can't put teaching
assistants within a classroom I can't
meet the needs that those youngsters and
families they're just legitimate and I
feel as though I'm letting people down
and that's not fair all the time my
staff are being asked to do more and
more with much less I mean the
government say that one is going up so
yeah well I mean it's the same old same
old isn't it yes money is going up there
also 3/4 of a million more children in
our school since 2010 that's why the
money is going up in real terms the
money is going down we need really
significant investment do you think it
will perhaps decide the next election I
think it will have a profound effect and
I think that that is why it's talked
about so much but we need all of the
parties to actually recognize the
important education but come up with
coherent plans as well most head teacher
will tell you we want education to be
free of political interference we're
really good professionals fund us
properly resources properly give us some
teachers and we will do the rest
these four boys benefit from a
specialist literacy class every week
they're studying Charlie and the
Chocolate Factory the school would like
to provide more lessons like this but
they don't have the staff 14 percent of
pupils at Tam Bridge house are on the
special needs register but the number of
teaching assistants has gone down
because of budget pressures we could be
talking about children that have got
autism perhaps ADHD dyslexic students
but of course we've also got a lot of
students who might have special
educational needs but also it's their
well-being needs and and all the
pressures increasing they are because we
have to do more of what we in the past
would have been able to rely on outside
agencies for watching what kind of a
speech and language therapist and we do
have a great therapist who comes in once
twice a year but it's only to work with
very specific students and is that
because the council budgets are going
down as well yes the county can't
provide those resources anymore and we
can't afford to buy them in either so
we're having to do ourselves in
Westminster the Education Select
Committee has been investigating special
needs provision and its chair Robert
Halfin is worried by what he's found
every day in our country there are
thousands of parents struggling
who have children with special
educational needs literally struggling
wading through treacle trying to get the
right provision the right care the right
education for their child with special
educational and needs and it's wrong
this is wrong if the National Health
Service can have a ten year plan if the
National Self Service can have twenty
billion extra of taxpayer funding which
I welcome
why on earth why on earth does an
education have a ten year plan
why on earth can't education get a five
year funding settlement a spokesperson
from the Department for Education said
the Education Secretary has made it
clear that high-needs funding is
priority and he recognizes the
challenges that local authorities and
schools face that's why he is committed
to working with the sector on this as we
approach the spending review in December
we provided an extra 250 million pounds
up to 2020 to help local authorities
manage high needs cost pressures this
takes the total allocated for high needs
to six point three billion pounds this
year compared to five billion in 2013
Tam Bridge House is clearly an
outstanding school but it's operating
under a seriously stretched budget and
they're not alone we've seen emails from
schools in Staffordshire Lancashire
Essex and Somerset and they're all
saying the same thing but they don't
have the money to fully support children
with complex needs in the way they want
it with a conservative leadership
contest looming and brexit still unsold
school funding is at risk of dropping
down the political agenda but if there
is a general election before 2022 its
issues like education that could decide
the outcome